online challenge for korea 2021 infested
gonna be going up
against cbm and it's gonna be the gin
going up against infested's [ __ ] mom
okay
yes and this is uh the [ __ ] rum that
made into top eight in the last uh dojo
tournament
uh we'll see uh what what infest it has
he does uh he does also have a negan so
he could switch to that
still first to two best of three
and uh we got cherry bear mangoes gin
round one character he's famous yeah
this is great
i think jen is you know despite you know
doing so well in these tournaments
around the world still a character that
everyone kind of does not expect is very
good like yeah no no you mean devil gin
right that's the one to test here yeah
yeah oh
it's blocked there on the down back four
cool another block on the low infested
a slow start nice trade
they're kind of feeling each other out
right now down forward one four
definitely
wow wow and he tried for the big one
yeah
yeah he went for it
[Applause]
is so good it's like minus 15 on block i
think but it's
so fast and you don't ever think it's
that punishable
yeah
look out nice period
okay
barry mango one of the best gym players
out there
nice duck there
is the wall splat
big damage here infested looking
like he's gonna take this round oh
looking for a 4-4 counter hit or
something damn 3-1 he's gonna do it
again
oh running three plus frames oh
yeah
it's fantastic
still looking like him trying to find
his groove here
and that port four is no
oh man
yeah an investor just showing off
aquarium's range
yeah that's the specialty of the
character right in addition to his like
guards the guard breaks at the wall
etcetera yeah and yeah this started off
pretty good cbm was looking pretty sharp
you know yeah the pairing of the can can
yeah and i i started thinking of that
moment like dude maybe
maybe this is characters good against
all of them characters right
funny stereo yep time though
yeah they're keeping it really slow
careful oh okay that's it with the lead
now it's gonna be hard
three seconds left oh just yeah
yeah couldn't really
do much after that looking for hail mary
ray i i just i just think infested just
shut him out it's like no you don't get
to play the problem
the end of that round though was you
know cbm ducked the high in the string
and he did nothing like in that
situation time's winding down if you're
gonna commit to a duck you've got to be
ready you know to hit a button afterward
if there's only three seconds on the
clock if he had just done while standing
two rage already he probably winged that
round
continuing
uh you know so
that was a a huge mistake at the end but
overall you know there's just very good
space control coming out of uh infested
and you know you're not really seeing
cbm using jin's forward four as much uh
which i feel like would be one of the
tools you're trying to use especially
against focus because he's gonna try to
hit you from this range that's so far
away you know if he tries to reach out
that forward for eclipse you he's going
to get a counter combo right so
uh yeah it's kind of curious that we
haven't seen that on a cbm just yet but
you know you mentioned he has a large
maybe we'll see a character switch here
uh infested's focus
looks very compact right he's not really
trying to do too much of the character
just using the three one a lot in the
rounds uh if i'm cbm i'm looking
especially for that three one though
right like just to duck that the one in
it and get a punish on it
gonna switch stage here sticks to
geometric plane gonna be where we go for
cbm
uh yeah he didn't really get anything
started cbm was playing really hesitant
that first game
yeah and investors was just uh you know
basically playing keep out and um
yeah he had a couple tried a couple of
four fours but nothing was connecting
really and he just kind of like
he just kind of like uh froze up i think
round one
well let's see what happens game two now
to kick things off
oh there you go
there we go here's something to get
things started
oh it's blocked there we're so hard
mango
good cotton
yeah oh back to one
yeah using these uh
yeah using these moves to look at that
range
man he wants that electric again too
yeah stop this
oh okay
magic forward
fairy berry mango going towards the wall
infested
mix up hatchet kick
moon cbm doesn't bite there
it has to try to get the walls flat down
by four tracks so far the right time
yeah that was that that was very tracked
a couple of one jabs to get things
started but backing off hook fist
there's everything a little bit more
active
yeah he is but he's really having a hard
time finding infested with weight man
he's trying for that part just do
something simple you know just you do
the forward one plus two punch or
something get the 14 frame instead
or the easier force your favorite is
that but time wind down
and at that point it's too late right
like your options are so limited
uh that it's obvious it's much more
obvious that you're gonna go for the lrk
yeah no sir
is that a range there that downpour
[Music]
infested just he looks pretty
comfortable but care bear mango
definitely
pushing a little harder
hey it's blocked
yeah very compact we might see
time running out
he got that low parry off of the sides
i'm not even doing wall carries gonna be
here for him
oh there is hell for four counter hit
care berry mango
great execution
and that's the front there's that move
yeah that does so much damage oh my god
and it comes out so fast you're like you
don't expect it yes that's the thing
right like infested he's playing really
good back dash keep out game uh and so
eventually cherry mango is getting
impact he's dashing in and then the back
one's just waiting for him
yeah surprising
oh no there we go
he gets the period for the first one
oh no
and this is best of three here infested
looking
to put another
super strong player on his list
he's like i got a knee i got john ding
and i'm looking at cbm right now
cbm though backing up this corner last
chance
can we see a rage drive maybe
he's like i'm chilling bro
yeah invested
so patient oh my god
yeah i mean it's great like what do you
do i got the standing down to keep out
exactly i got this backward if you want
to get real crazy now
oh okay next time commuter but
getting chloe checked away now five
seconds oh my god that's his blue stuff
oh we're gonna do that corey gaming
video when the players about to win they
just freeze up and stop playing that
game telling you yes
why do they keep doing it
yeah everybody played that really well
he just chopped him away
yes
that one does so much damage yes
oh and the wall
more combos uh-huh oh cans
yo everything falling
wow
cbm cherry berry mango staying alive
another game and infest is going to look
back at that it's going to be part of
the corey video next time i'm telling
you guys
he's like i got this game one i won the
whole set back back back back
back back back how did i lose how did i
lose the whole game
i was winning yeah i just stopped doing
everything that was working you know
yeah damn and it was kind of working for
a while but like cherry brain man we're
kind of new and he's like okay i know
and i'm gonna push forward like if
you're gonna do that i'm gonna push you
towards the wall and that's the thing
about back dashing away and back that's
bad guys back dash when there's a wall
stage i mean eventually you can't back
dash any further and basically a cherry
barrier mango is like all right i'm just
gonna like keep on poking you and he's
attacking more and at that moment he's
just it was like
at one point you're just like oh he just
poked him a bunch like how was he like
evening it up and then he was able to
take it at the end there so it adds up
especially with rage
yeah and that's the pace that's the
patient play that you expect from you
know players at this level too right i
mean they're
to be able to just do that and not go in
and try something crazy or risky or do a
health sweep there you know um a lot of
lesser players would have uh succumbed i
think
and also you know the the four four and
the zen one plus two like that's
something that we hadn't really seen cbm
go to uh and i think yeah it's one of
those situations where he was playing
too respectful right he's like oh no
this is yeah this is you know top in the
winner's side if i win i'm in winter's
final i can't make any mistakes i can't
take any risks uh but then at the end
he's like nah man it's it's a video game
yeah
yeah that's a book definitely uh likes
that zen
uh
one plus two or one two right
all right let's see final game here
infinite stage
interesting choice for different stage
infested was the one who had the stage
choice
[Music]
and i mean it kind of makes sense right
i mean do you think [ __ ] was good with
the wall but confess his playstyle as
we've seen has been very patient very
totally throws out the high there though
and cbm this time gets the duck walking
to full launch combo
carriberry mango so scary when he has
this momentum going
i felt that one round two invested
things may be falling apart or cbm may
have built up some confidence by winning
that last game
[Music]
oh no
jet kick
all right he's been trying to find us
but he hasn't right that was the first
one he landed on first try
running three plus frames oh going back
now oh
hitting running
[Music]
wow terribly mango
are we playing this game taking
advantage of his rage boost yes infested
the back ones getting i have a lead
yeah and cherry berry mango knows
oh god never lie now he's lost too much
health now yeah
yeah yeah
oh we had to punish on a on a hook this
that's crazy
nice choice she had the duck again
cbm's gotta pull the trigger yeah he's
getting these ducks he's hyped and he
could win the rounds with them
yeah
he's not hitting anybody you get the
hard part yeah
oh okay nothing you got he pressed
something there
yes yes press something right hit
something
good
okay
there might be another one coming
yeah oh so much respect from both these
players
oh hook fist
yeah and infested doesn't want to get
hit by those
of course he healey gets hit by electric
right now he's gonna lose his round
seconds yeah this is dangerous though
oh
was too late yeah he he better on the
hopkick there
set point for infested now yes
are we gonna get a final final round
here
i don't know about this one man
i feel like he's got control he's just
poking with the down forwards and
standing yeah oh man
oh look at this just oh and he gets that
no blocks no punishment
magic look at this where does life go
cherry berry mango
infested puts another player
on his list
you just made the list me chunting
and cherry barry mango just made the
list of players that he's taken out and
now he's the winner's final just like
that
this is it and mexico could take this
whole thing he could take this whole
he's using great